Salem has released a remix of the title
track off for album lover and it
features one of the biggest Canadian
stars in a world there is a new version
of lover coming a remix featuring
someone who I'm such a huge fan of who
I've known for a really long time and
someone that I've always really been
dying to collaborate with so drumroll
please it is featuring shawn mendes and
he has taken lover and he's rewritten
parts of it which i think is so
important because i love him as a writer
and I also think that everybody would
write a different love letter to their
lover and I think his take on it is so
beautiful I can't wait free to hear it
I'm so so so excited about this and I
hope you are too I'm excited are you
Sean wrote his own lyrics that actually
replaced the second verse the Taylor
original wrote so here's a bit of his
part in the lover remix
[Music]
no money
hmmm love it I mean I love that song I
know it's a great song like one of the
best I was just doing new song together
yeah yeah Lisa I was appreciate that at
least he wrote new lyrics for it like I
love their voices together because I
hate some of these remixes they're just
it's totally like a money grab they're
just like whatever they do two lines
they just kind of stupid in there
believe it this feels a little bit
integrated like doing duet together sure
fine but this is all a business game
like you want to do new versions of
these songs because the remixes count
for totals right right so like when you
do four or five different remixes of one
song all those points are for that one
song so it will help it stay at number
one it's not like the remix and the
original occupy two different spaces
right it's like they're all big they all
become the same sort of song when it
comes to downloads and streams or
everything else but I would like to see
Taylor and Shawn Mendes do a track
together I think in in that case anyway
their voices go really great together I
just love that song so much that I don't
know if that's needed for anything other
than a stunt right yeah and I do oh but
I do appreciate it at least yeah he
wrote new lyrics for it it's like and I
like the old Lee right no looks like I
just think you didn't completely folded
they just like fine I'll just sing her
now same so at least like he put some
effort into it like obviously it's such
a well written song so it's kind of
daunting from the write new lyrics for
it but yeah so yeah I think in that way
it works yeah I enjoy their voices
together so loose FLC you change their
mind
I like it okay